you say there's there's four main
pillars uh
uh four four main pillars to success
with women look status money game
what area do most guys lack in you know
money I guess you that's a give or take
in general
so I've actually expanded that because I
had a few
um coaching clients that were very
successful they had they had a lot of
that stuff status money looks you know
they're in really good shape sort of
stuff and I had to add captivation to
that list
and also being unplugged you know as
well
um so now there's being being unplugged
from the lies looks money status game
frame and captivation
um I think the captivation part gets
overlooked a lot especially by the guys
in like um you know the dating sphere
the like a lot of these younger kids are
just like looks money game is all that
matters sort of thing it's like no
because if you're loaded and you're 50
or 60 years old and you've been through
a marriage or two and you're divorced
um and you're boring you don't have
hobbies
you think you're going to get girls
stick around if you're boring as [__] no
like you you have to lead a captivating
life I was talking to this guy one time
and he's like you know rich I got lots
of money I love over Landing my uh I
can't remember what is a Jeep or
something like that in the Arizona
desert sort of thing he goes but I have
the hardest time getting getting girls
and keeping girls I'm like you're
kidding right we're on video you know he
calls into my podcast show we're on
video and I said you're a good looking
guy how tall are you what do you weigh
okay so you're not fat you know you're
in good shape and you're tall I'm like
why aren't they sticking around well you
know this that and the other thing I
would go what do you do that's fun you
know like what what activities are you
doing that you invite them into
he's like well I do this stuff with my
buddies I'm like here's here's the plan
buddy the next girl the next girl that
you invite out on a date like for date
number two like just do a coffee date
you know do a a sniff test see if you
dig her vibe see if she's interested in
you just do that for the first date I go
second date you're gonna do an over
Landing Adventure you're gonna instruct
her to pack a picnic okay because you
guys are gonna be out there for a few
hours and you're gonna take her to see
the best Sunset she's ever seen you know
a place where you can do that right oh
yeah I got this Canyon this is whatever
place it's called good so you're gonna
Park the Jeep there she's gonna roll out
the picnic long story short they spend
the night together right she has the
best time ever he can't keep like he's
got girls that won't leave him now right
like captivation is an incredibly
important part of attracting and
retaining women because as they say you
can do anything to a woman you want
except for her yeah I think that
motorcycle thing's uh is number one
because I never get you know throwing
around the back I mean I think the bikes
number one
all right man I I miss motorcycles so
much I'm so tempted to get another one I
was just gonna tell you that I you know
I live in Florida now when I lived up
north
you know it was more safe down here in
Florida you got half of Florida's God's
waiting room they can't see and then the
other half drive like complete lunatics
I mean complete lunatics right I mean I
mean not so when I came down here no
helmet laws there either too right so a
lot of guys roll without helmets no no
you should see these guys I mean they're
if they're because there's a lot of
traffic at five these guys go in and out
in and out and I've had them all the
Harleys the crop every but I've probably
had 15 bikes and when I see these guys
do this they'll come by me I go whoa and
I just I don't know how he's gonna make
it and down here what's funny is the
cops aren't allowed to chase them
because yeah it's it's a risk of
Interest yeah but every single week I
get this tempted to go back and get
because I miss that so much and when you
do have a girl there's nothing like it
you could be fighting for hours about
some [__] come on let's take a ride
on the bike you know yeah yeah if you
get a gal on the back of your bike and
you show her a good time that night yeah
she's yeah man she's totally hooked game
over yeah and what was the other one
that you had I thought I thought it
would have been uh charisma
uh well charisma's part of like having
having game with women it's you know
it's like built into that so again it's
unplugging or being unplugged from you
know society's lives because truthfully
women don't want sheep right like they
want to be with a giant they want to be
with a strong virtuous man that that
leads you got to be good looking right
like you can't have bad Style bad
clothing unkept untidy you got to make
the most out of what you get you know if
you're losing your hair shave your head
if you're losing your hair get a hair
transplant you know if that's an option
like just do something right so the
looks component having money you can't
be poor women like successful men men
are success objects so get your money
sorted out status
um having a nice online presence is
great you don't need much you know you
don't have to be an influence or
anything like that or have a podcast or
anything but you know if you're
competent you're funny you do good
things you have good friends you you
have a good social network take some
pictures while you're out and post them
on Instagram when you meet women they're
like hey what's your Instagram you know
they want to look you up they want to do
their research searched on you
especially with their committee right so
there's that having some status you know
when I walk into the sushi restaurant
that I frequent there's this Boutique
one where the Japanese guy it's a very
small place like four or five tables I
don't know Mr Cooper like you know like
they like they show the respect you know
they bring you know they bring to you
what you want when you want it right
they're very like and they know you're
having stuff yeah they know your name
right you know having such a game with
women knowing how to play them you know
and not play them in a detrimental or a
mean way but no but know how to be
playful with women right like game is
part of that having frame so again you
know you you set healthy boundaries
around the relationship hey Rich I
wanted to claim you and I want to share
you you know where do we stand okay cool
but I don't take women seriously that
post provocative pictures on social
media so
what are we stand with that first of all
you know sort of thing like that's what
frame is you know having some boundaries
with women sort of thing and of course
there's a captivation which is the
seventh one
what is what is it with these guys like
like their hairline's almost back to
their neck and they just don't shave it
they don't [__] and like even like uh
Lebron James he's been down here and got
37 I mean the guy's got a ton of money
he's got 37 hair transplants just shave
it like what is it I just shaved the
[__] I don't know some people I know
some people are like I don't like the
shape of my head or they got moles on
their head or whatever reason I don't
know it's like the whole Seinfeld
episode when Elaine was made making fun
of George was like you know you're just
holding on to scraps you know that
always stuck with me it's like you know
I kept the hair as long as I did and
then when it wasn't working out then I
just clipped it down and I shaved it
right like
so what it's just hair right like I have
no Pro like okay there's whip there's
some women that don't like guys that are
bald fine there's like 70 of the
population that still does who cares
right like it doesn't matter but people
get very very self-conscious about
things like that it's not I if and even
like the actors you know I've seen them
do it they'll play big roles in the
movies yeah like uh what's his name uh
Matthew McConaughey like his hairline is
a mystery right like it's got it's
gotten better and better over time and
possibly better and better over time
right yeah there's there's entire
YouTube channels that are dedicated to
analyzing somebody's hairline when they
got their graphs well how they did it
it's like the obsession is real right
you should see uh Bradley Coopers we we
have Bradley Cooper coming out we had a
joke to them prior you should they have
the [__] doctor that he went to build
a site and in his SEO it's like Bradley
Cooper's hair transplant guy yeah and
then you could find 50 sites of the
paragraph or whatever and it wasn't that
much and it's they're so obsessed with
that and that's yeah it's just
self-conscious right well there's well
there's guys that will break their legs
now to gain two or three inches in
height I don't know if you've seen that
yeah I know I mean like guys
how insane do you have to be to break
your freaking legs to gain two or three
inches in height what do they do to
realistically get a very low tier check
anyway you know at the end of the day
Rich break your legs what do they do
stuff that's that's [__] nuts no no
no they no they literally break their
thigh legs and then they insert this uh
Pusher mechanism that that slowly
stretches out and Bone fills in the the
vacant space it's very painful there's
videos on YouTube about people that have
done this it's apparently it's
exceptionally painful what's the healing
process on that I wonder months months
it takes a long time to heal and even
then your legs will be three inches
longer but your arms will be the same
length you're gonna have a weird
proportions yeah you have to break your
arms though
that'll be the next thing is breaking
your arms to match your extra legs nuts
I I saw that I can like breaking your
leg buddy like it's that important to
break here like you know you see some of
these athletes have broken their legs
and like are you nuts like you're you
going to the doctor and put your leg up
there and say yes sir I I'd like two
[__] inches break my leg you know or
break my two legs and then show me how
to walk again too yeah I mean I've um no
I have friends that told me that they
were contemplating I said if you do that
I'm not gonna be your friend anymore
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out